- If you knew that 90% of your business
was how to do pictures
and videos on Facebook,
you would act differently every day.
This portrait is like with me.
So I think this is when
you need to get selfish,
like need to ask your question.
(upbeat music)
Hiring guessing, firing is knowing,
like you gotta go fast.
That's how you get (beep) done.
That's when you figure stuff out.
This is the television and
the television is the radio.
The 40s by the fathers.
- [Joe] There he is.
Hey Gary.
- Hey.
- [Gary] Thank you
- [Gary] Hey everyone.
How are you?
- [Ryan] Hey Gary
- Hey everybody.
Sorry about the confusion.
I had some wrong links.
I have a board meeting at one o'clock.
So I'm gonna go right
into it, would love to,
Joe Q, why don't you take the
lead and just pick on someone
please say hello, where you're from,
and then go right into your...
actually let's do intros first,
'cause it's good context for me.
So Joe, if you could just...
- [Joe] Yeah, so let's
start with Jason Williams,
the birthday boy
Jason, you're up flag.
Tell Gary who you are.
- [Jason] Hey Gary, Jason Williams
from Jack Williams Tire Company.
So we're a third generation
family business, 91 years old,
and recently launched the
new disruptive concept
of mobile tire installation.
So we've have 36 traditional
brick and mortar stores,
the whole new brand that we're launching
and just trying to launch
a new model out there.
- [Gary] I love it
- That's awesome.
- [Gary] I get it.
- We'll get right back
to you, Jason.
Gary, let's go down to
Daniel and Michael Yu Ha
in Honduras, Yu Ha brothers say hello.
- Hey, how's it going, Gary,
very happy to be here.
- [Daniel] Hi Gary
We have, we own a family
business as well of 50 years.
We're a hardware store.
We're into wholesale retail, franchise
and e-commerce as well
both for retail and for a B2B.
- Awesome, real nice to meet
you Michael, nice to meet you.
- [Joe] Toby, over in Barbados,
say hello to Gary.
- What's happening Gary,
nice to see you man
- [Gary] Hi Toby,
good to see you
- We got two retail stores,
building a third store.
We got e-commerce presence also.
We are selling high-end
power tools and equipment
to Barbados the country, Barbados.
- To the B2B, or to the
consumers of Barbados
- Both B2B and B2C.
- Well said, thank you.
- [Joe] Let's keep the outside
of the continental us
flare going,and Hawaii.
- Hey Gary.
- Zach and Courtney here.
Where Sage Creamery.
- [Gary] I remember.
- [Zach] Thanks.
- I remember the whole thing.
It's good to see you guys
again, I'll be ready.
- Yeah.
- Okay, thank you.
- Let's swing back into the United States,
but let's go down to Florida,
Geo and Antonio from stream
media, say hello to Gary.
You're on mute or we can't
hear your audio guys.
- We can't hear you.
- [Geo] How you doing?
This is Geo and Antonio from stream media.
So we're the most
innovative and interactive
OTT streaming platform in the world.
So we work with content providers
to provide our technology,
so they can build the next generation;
Netflix, Spotify, OTT,
direct to consumer solutions.
So obviously our business is booming.
We're launching two new
products direct to consumer
and we'd love to hear what you think.
- Awesome, thank you my friend.
- [Gary] Ryan, we're working
our way up the coast.
Ryan Smith in Georgia say hello to Gary.
- Hey Gary, how are you doing?
- I'm doing very well.
How are you?
- I'm doing well.
Thank you.
Thanks for allowing me to be here.
I also wanted to wish you a
slightly late happy birthday.
- Thank you
- I believe that you're not
even close to halftime yet,
so just keep doing it.
- [Gary] Thank you
- So I have a very small start-up
home theater design
company that my wife and I
are trying to build. So that
way I can get out of the job
that I'm not very happy doing.
And I'm just thankful to be here
and learning everything
that I can from you guys.
- Thank you so much.
- [Joe] And Lauren Martin
from Franklin, Tennessee
who's got a burgeoning business
in the field of therapy.
Go ahead and say hi to Gary.
- Hi Gary. I think you'd
like my shirt says,
"Practice radical empathy."
- [Gary] Love.
- Nice.
So I am here because I wanna go
from being a therapist in the
chair to developing products,
digital products for clients.
What I wanna launch next year is the idea
of a solo self guided retreat,
where you have videos, PDFs,
guided prompts for the day,
so that you have the retreat experience
but on your own, COVID friendly.
- [Joe] Awesome.
And Christopher up in Milwaukee,
go ahead and say hi to Gary.
- Hey Gary, how are you doing great?
Really happy to be here.
So I have a medical practice,
but I treat foot and
ankle, a single location,
scaled it down to scale it up.
So sold a couple of my offices
and I wanna scale it up
at the great location.
And then I coach and
consult with podiatrists.
I wanna be able to scale up, use digital,
just really get better at doing that,
and then be able to coach
other people to do it as well.
- I understand.
- [Joe] And finally, we're gonna
bring it home, with Esther,
Who's the closest to you, Gary.
She's in the Tri-State
Esther say hi to Gary
- Hi Gary, how are you,
good morning or afternoon.
Am not gonna waste time, I
think Gary knows me already.
- I have all the context in you Esther.
- [Esther] And happy birthday.
- Thank you so much.
Thank you so much.
All right, let's go back around
the horn, Jason fire away.
And team, this is where you go very narrow
with your question.
Obviously the four Ds
program will give you a ton
of context, but I want
you to go very narrow.
And what we've learned through the years
is a lot of times it
helps everybody else too
from a different angle.
So it's exciting, but
be selfish, go narrow.
- Okay, so we're launching
a new, a disruptive brand.
So a disruptive model as well as a brand.
So people were having some challenges,
just connecting a van,
coming to your house
to change your tires
versus for the last 90 years,
going into a brick and mortar.
So trying to figure out how
we could be more strategic
in driving appointments.
So there's a certain
number of appointments
that we need to do each day per van,
as well as...
- Are they your own operated and own van?
- Yes.
Yes.
So we have those, they're
all there in different
- How much first party data
do you have prior customers
through the years?
- Well, we're trying to knock to target
our traditional customers.
So we're looking for new
customers in the markets.
- I think that might be a mistake
which is why I'm asking the question.
Let me rephrase,
I think you should a hundred
percent target new customers.
To bacK to the question, brother.
Do you have the information
of all your customers through the years?
- Yes.
We could get it,
I mean changing systems
recently, but we them.
- You would have email at least.
- [Jason] Yes.
- Address.
- Yes.
- [Gary] I would uncomfort...
this the number one mistake people make
when they go to a new
format for their service
is literally what you walked into,
which is like, "This is not
gonna be the same customers.
"These are people that don't wanna come.
"They're gonna be younger."
It's the cliche mistake.
The,
you have to market
in two ways in parallel,
but your historical client,
Rick 58 years old, in
Pittsburgh that walked
into your store six years
ago and has never come back.
But the data sits in
one of your old systems
is the first person I'm
sending a direct mail piece to
and an email.
- Okay.
- [Gary] Lapsed users from the old model,
because you're sitting on the data,
you know that they would
even consider what you do.
- [Gary] The money you're gonna spend,
trying to get all of us.
I would never do what you do.
I've leased all my car.
I don't even think,
like I don't think I've
changed my oil in any car
in my 27 years of ownership
or tires or any, like no shot.
You can spend a billion (beep) dollars.
You'd tell me about the jets.
You can talk to me about wine.
It's not happening.
You're sitting on a gold mine
of data of people that would consider it.
And don't think that, James
Orsini how old are you?
- 57.
- Beautiful.
Don't assume that James,
just because he's 57
doesn't value his time.
And wouldn't love for
you to come to his house.
Instead of him going to
one of your location.
- [James] This book set of
tires this week got ripped off,
run flats for that small
Mercedes, my daughter rip me off.
- So Jason, to that point,
I think you start...
So to plan attack, for every,
this is going to matter
for everybody, for screaming,
for Geo and Antonio,
for all of you, ice cream, whoever's best
at spending the least amount of money,
running ads and making pictures and videos
to get people to consider
their business will win.
That's it?
Nothing else.
That's all I've done for 25 years, right?
That's why I like TikTok.
That's why I like LinkedIn right now.
That's why I like creators and PCS.
And every single thing
that comes out of my mouth.
Now, bucketing your two
groups into historical clients
and new clients is where you have to go.
I'll give you a couple of tips
that you have to master
Facebook, creative and media.
Facebook, not Facebook Inc.
Not Instagram.
Yes, Instagram, but for
your business to work
for the math to work
on what your overhead is on your own vans,
you're gonna, your
company's gonna need to be,
have to be great at Facebook
because it's this most scaled
cheapest, and in the pocket
of the age group that I
think you will convert best
on your product.
For Zack and Courtney, it's Instagram.
For you, it's Facebook.
For Zack and Courtney,
it's Instagram story ads
that swipe up to their DTC or their store.
They'll run it different in Hawaii
because it's come to the store
as they will with shipping.
Got it?
So there's nuances within it,
for you, pictures and videos.
Now, when you're doing a new thing,
doing videos on your phone
even, that are a little silly
and a little different,
you need to teach people
that it's cool for people
to come to their house.
So the creative, the things,
there's a mill, as all of you know,
there's millions of people on the internet
that try to be like Gary Vee, right?
There's a lot of people talking
about business advice,
motivation, content, social.
It becomes a game of who's best.
So not all, and I'm talking
about in the content.
So the tire, the...
it's insane how the world works today now.
The business is imperative,
you have to have a good business,
a good product getting ripped,
but James just got ripped off.
- Right?
- [Gary] It's why he
considered that business.
Then it's shopper at
Google, did he say that?
Was it word of mouth from somebody?
One of the reasons I want you to hit up
all your current clients is for the 8%
of them that take you
up on this new service.
They're gonna be the loudest
people at dinner tables
talking about your service.
Hey Jane, once we get back from COVID,
Hey, Jane.
What I did this week?
It's crazy.
Jack, like they came to my house.
Got it.
- [Jason] Yup.
So that's a follow-up.
So the other part is entering new markets,
and we're also moving to
franchising the concept as well.
- Right.
So if you look at all
the mobile fitness stuff
and the other stuff that
you're probably looking
at for this model junk and all that stuff,
it's the same game brother.
Like you have to have a
massive marketing strategy
to build awareness in a marketplace,
and you have to create
awareness for your brand.
So that franchisees come in,
I'm sitting on mic in 40 minutes
which is why I'm just gonna
shut you come through.
By the way, anybody who I missed,
we're gonna schedule some
five and 10 minute versions
of this, because I'm
not gonna let you down.
So don't stress as the time goes on here.
The other thing to think about
is the recruitment at my board meeting
at one o'clock is Bojangles,
the chicken restaurant
down in the Carolinas.
I know I'm leading up the
task force to do content
on LinkedIn to get franchisees.
So it, brother, and I'm telling you this
is why I'm staying on this one,
'cause this is the answer
to literally, to everybody.
There's nothing even close to as important
as knowing how to run
media on social media
and how to make content
that works in social media.
There's nothing even close left.
So, you can acquire franchisees
with a crazy LinkedIn strategy,
because you're making
content about entrepreneurs
that don't want to take the full risk.
Get it?
You're gonna to have to own Facebook
'cause you can target
people 48 to 57, right?
Who are car enthusiasts,
who also like the Steelers.
And in that video, you're talking about,
remember of the bus, Jerome Bettis.
Well, we were like, we both bring the bus
like you see where I'm going.
- [Jason] Yeah
- And then that video goes well,
and you're like, wait a minute,
maybe we should reach out to
Jerome Bettis and sure enough,
Jerome Bettis is washed up
athlete. Let's call it what it is
and hope for $10,000 be in your videos.
And now you covert,
this is a forever living
and breathing machine.
- Hey Gary.
- [Gary] Yeah, go ahead Joe.
- I was gonna say we,
in respect to time, we should
probably move on a little bit.
- Please, good job Joe.
I thank you for it.
Thank you for executing
on what I told you to
do when I went in here.
- [Joe] No problem.
Why don't we go keeping the same order?
Why don't we go down to Honduras
and talk to the Yu Ha
brothers, Daniel or Michael.
Want to chime in and
ask Gary your question?
- All right, thank you.
Hi Gary.
So actually that bit about franchising
was really helpful for us.
We're involved in that space as well.
Well, I don't know how many
times a day you get this
but I dropped out of
college because of you.
It was last year and...
- Were your parents upset with me?
- [Daniel] No, actually
they were the only ones
who supported me.
So everyone else told me not to do it.
- [Gary] Lucky boy.
- [Daniel] That's really...
- Lucky boy.
- [Daniel] Yeah.
- Remind everybody...
- Remind your brother and everybody else,
you can always go back.
- [Daniel] Yeah, I do.
I do.
I'm not going.
- [Gary] I get it.
- So basically, since last year we started
this franchise concept
and my brother and I
we've lived in the States.
I've lived in Europe.
And so we've seen all of
these different businesses
out there, the whole environment there.
And when we come back here, it's like,
we want so many things to change.
So really we're set
out on this mission to make something,
make sort of this vehicle
that will allow us
to go into other businesses.
We've been focusing on
hardware, all our lives.
Our families have been.
So we're trying to branch out
and get into other things,
B2B, e-commerce platform services,
consulting, retail,
- [Gary] Makes sense.
Infrastructure.
So yeah, we were sort of,
we're interested in your
experience as Vayner X,
this machine that you've
built and the idea
of how much time do we spend operating
versus managing a business,
I'm programmer, so how
do I balance my time
in building a platform versus
managing everything around it.
- Patients.
Right?
I mean,
- [Daniel] Yeah.
It was seven years of VaynerMedia
before there was an M and A activity.
So patients, putting in the
work based on your ambition.
So, I don't know you too,
and I don't want you to burn out,
but if you have this big ambition,
because I operate and manage
and I'm Gary Vee, right?
And so why I say that is,
I wanna know what your 24
hours look like, I really do.
Now if you have patients,
you don't have to burn out.
But the way you manage it as more time
like I was, for example,
every day during COVID
like I'm basically at
14 hours every minute,
no lunch, no dinner in
front of the computer,
and really 8:00 AM to 9:00 PM,
like just right there, 12,
13, 14, or every minute.
That's a lot of output in one day,
that's 13, 14 hours of work.
A lot of people who have big ambitions,
when they really audit it,
they did this for an hour,
in the middle of the day,
they took care of this personal matter,
like how many hours of output?
And then if your ambition is big,
because you're talking big,
is you're both so young.
And before you say anything,
Daniel, you're so young.
So you're both so young
that it's okay to be eight
hours, but you just need to know
that that's gonna then take 14 years.
- [Daniel] Yeah.
- [Gary] It's net hours.
- I think we understand
the patient's component.
And there's just so much
that we want to get done.
And I know we have to be patient.
- I wanna do so much too.
I think you do one at a time,
whenever you go into your,
so for example, the first
thing you do outside
the thing you've always known,
you need to be focused
on that for many years,
because don't forget my expansion.
Wasn't something completely different.
They were all in the same basic realm.
The gallery media group is talking
to the same customers of intermediate.
Sasha is just part of the Gary Vee
ecosystem and VaynerMedia,
'cause it's all just kind of connected.
So it's not like, for example,
even though I successfully did Rezi
and I successfully did Empathy Wines,
I wasn't able to impact those businesses
the way I'm impacting this.
So the second they become two different,
it's almost like a whole,
I did like an overlap,
not like a separate.
Got it.
- [Daniel] Yeah.
- [Gary] Keep that in mind
- Yeah.
- Yeah, I have a, another
quick question about franchise.
We launched our franchise
business five days
before we got into quarantine,
which was back in March.
And that we've been hit by
a hurricane two weeks ago
and hit by another one this week.
So it's kind of tough
getting new franchisees,
asking people to invest 100K, 80K
into new retail stores.
- You have any franchisees?
- We have a, no, we have
a, the our a model store
was launched in March and
then we got into quarantinne.
So we have a bunch of leads
but people just don't feel like investing.
- [Gary] Yeah
I think you should build
community right now.
- Okay.
- [Gary] You should
Zooms and LinkedIn things
and just build relationships
and don't even ask to close
call it franchise advisory sessions.
- Okay.
- And you start off with like we're here
to just talk about it in the macro,
business in the macro, marketing
and the macro, franchisees.
Got it.
Build relationships.
- Yeah, because people love the business
that they just don't
wanna close right now,
people are talking 2021,
and so we just need
to have patients as you say.
- [Gary] 100% brother.
- [Joe] On that theme,
Gary, Toby has been down
and he's a Brit, hanging
out down in Barbados.
He's been there for 13 years.
He's in a similar industry
to the Yu Ha brothers,
but Toby, why don't you go ahead
and fire up a question to Gary Vee.
- [Toby] Yes, great.
Gary, my first question would be,
we've been doing unique contact every day.
So we will push 365 a year
unique pieces of content
every piece of content we've done
it doesn't have a face in it.
Do you think that we
should be putting a face
in it to Scale the business?
- I don't think you have to.
I don't think you have to.
I think you should, you could consider it.
I think if there's two ways of faces,
there's Hussein Bolt or there's Gary Vee
are you saying yourself and your team,
or are you saying other
people that you rent equity
from like a famous Barbados influencer?
- It could be either,
but because of, when he
gets technical with product,
it might have to be an internal face.
- I think you should do that,
because people trust humans.
So I think, I would do it,
but I don't think you have to.
- Okay.
- [Gary] Does that makes sense?
- Yeah, for sure.
The only slight nervousness
on it is being oversea,
a white Englishman in a
different environment,
which is 95% dark pigmentation,
different local wine sets.
- And I think that's a great call-out.
Do you feel like the
market would be over...
One of the things you
can do is with a co-host,
maybe it's you and,
- Okay
- [Gary] somebody internal
or maybe it's always
four people, it's like
a round table discussion
on the content.
So maybe it's two internal,
one external, former client
current client, somebody
else that's in the space.
So you can make the format less
about one person and more about several.
- Okay, cool.
That's great.
Can I fire a quick, a few quick questions?
- Yeah.
- [Toby] When I'm talking about marketing,
I'm not holding a lot of the content,
but would you ever recommend
what sort of marketing
percent of revenue we would
spend on a marketing budget?
- Me personally, every
dollar I could afford.
- [Toby] Okay.
- I believe in it.
I believe marketing is
more important than money.
- Because you'll get the return
or confident on getting a return.
- Yeah, because I don't,
because I would think
if you're not marketing digitally today,
you're actually gonna go out of business.
- [Toby] Understood.
- Like over time, it's just gonna corrode.
So I think the stakes are
higher than people realize.
- Okay.
Changing genre a little bit,
how would you motivate an employee
that's not motivate motivated by money?
- By giving them what
they're motivated by.
My,
There is a huge mistake
the business owner makes,
people are motivated by different things.
And if that person's motivated
by a three-day weekend on Fridays,
you have to consider it.
Now, if you're scared
of that sets a precedent
for other people, you
can just speak to them
and say, "Let's just use people in here."
Ryan comes to you and says,
"Hey why Zach and Jason off on Fridays,
"and I'm (beep) working here?"
And I say, "Ryan they're taking less money
"to be off on Friday.
"If you wanna take a
20% cut on your salary,
"you can have Friday off."
- [Toby] That's it.
Yeah.
- It really works.
This was something my
father couldn't understand.
He thinks everyone should
be motivated by money.
I think, cause he was,
he thought everybody
should work as hard as him.
And I was like, "They work for you,
"it's not their business."
And he was very inflexible,
he thought they should be motivated
by what he wanted them to be motivated by.
I have a very, very reverse model to that.
- [Toby] Cool.
Is there any lifestyle habits,
that helped you become successful?
- The ability not to judge myself,
the mental lifestyle
aspect of understanding
I'm human, I'm far from perfect,
I have good intent,
I have to be patient,
I like people, I'm in business
which means a lot of times
it's not gonna be good.
And that mentality is,
the mental lifestyle
is what got me to where I am.
Cheers, Let's move it on Joe.
- Yeah, so let's keep it
on mental health actually.
So Lauren Martin up in
Franklin, Tennessee,
she practices in that space a lot.
So Lauren what...
- [Gary] Joe, I need to
give you a huge shout out.
There's little segues are
very, very, very good.
I'm impressed Joe.
- I had all day yesterday,
getting know these people.
- Yes, but just that's one thing,
but doing the improv skills
of natural things that are coming
out of my mouth and
segueing, I am quite...
I'm not kidding, I'm very impressed.
Lauren what's up?
- Hi, I wanna pivot from therapy.
So right now all of my contents branded
under novel counseling
'cause like novel, like
new ways of thinking.
I'm considering going into my own name,
since I'm the only employee.
I'm just wondering, if I'm wanting to do,
more personable content,
moving more into education.
I'll still have some clients.
- I have some really good news.
- [Lauren] Yeah.
- I lived this life.
I went from Wine Library TV.
I started Gary Vee,
and I started changing the
things that came out of my mouth
while still for a little
while, selling plenty of wine.
- [Lauren] Okay.
- The answer is I know it
better than anybody on earth.
I really mean that, because
I was at the top of my game.
Nobody was doing influencer
marketing and content 2006,
seven, eight, when I was doing it.
I got known as the wine guy,
dah, dah, dah, I want
to talk about business.
I lost 80% of my views.
- [Lauren] Yeah.
- I didn't care.
- Because you're doing what you want.
- [Gary] And I didn't lose
any percent of my business.
Got it.
So you'll maintain your business.
You'll start adding other
components to your world.
And then the world will
become your oyster.
- Cool.
- And all your usernames
immediately to your name.
- [Lauren] Okay.
- And make a manifesto video immediately
and saying "I'm still doing this,
"but I'm now in and land."
This is not for everybody.
This is not an old video.
- Hey, we're a big believer
in the and world and the therapy road,
It's a both and sort of life.
- You know what? That
makes a ton of sense to me,
given like all my natural nuances.
So that's cool to hear.
And that's what this is.
It's not like you're going into,
now you talk about jam or business
or whatever you're gonna go into.
You're gonna talk about both.
So this is an and video.
Now what I'm hearing, you could tie it
into the macro of what
you do to begin with.
And there it is.
And everyone's gonna be like,
"Congratulations, I'm proud of you, girl."
And all that, and you'll be on your way.
And some people be like, "Oh, I don't want
to hear that other stuff."
And I'll be fine too.
- [Lauren] Great.
Cool.
- [Gary] Immediately, immediately.
- Well, I'm going to do it tonight.
And then my husband's gonna be like,
of course you're gonna stay up,
until midnight doing all
the things, just go to bed.
So then I guess with that,
I'm wondering, so I had that,
and then I was curious about the viability
of like the self guided retreats,
but I got your initial reaction on that,
that like a digital
product is really viable,
especially in COVID world,
but also doing things
on your own time.
- [Gary] 100%
- I'm wondering if it makes sense
to sort of since I don't
have the product done,
I'm in the process of making the product.
If I should go ahead and just start
more of like an influencer
movement of creating things
like, I don't know if people have consider
doing solo retreats or
I think people do it,
but almost sort of branding it myself,
and then even if people
copy it, they copy it.
I don't give a (beep)
I just come up with...
- [Gary] Yeah.
- It is a good one.
I want everybody listening.
There's nothing in the world
that stops people from copying.
You should spend zero seconds on it.
It is the greatest waste
of time for entrepreneurs.
Yeah dont,
People worrying about
people copying (beep)
stops people from doing
(beep) when it didn't matter.
- Well, that's like where I've been stuck,
because I don't come
up with therapy models.
So I don't wanna be accused
of stealing therapy models.
But if I'm compiling all together
then that's my brain space.
- You're the DJ.
But make sure the world knows you're a DJ
because otherwise your event milli Vanilli
- I used to be a radio DJ.
So that's funny that you said.
- Even better after you are, you're a DJ
and you just have to make sure
that everybody knows that, and that's it.
and people value DJs.
I don't need you to be the creator of it.
You being the curator
of it is great for me.
So you should own that,
never hide from that.
- Awesome.
- [Joe] Let's stay in the medical world
and shipped over to Milwaukee.
Christopher, do you want to talk
about your podiatry practice?
- Absolutely, Yeah.
- [Gary] Chris, by the
way, Chris I'm so proud,
of you for being strategic
enough to take a step backwards
for three steps forward.
It is the cliche mistake
of almost everybody
in the kind of businesses that you have
and other doctors and of many
around that business model, kudos to you.
It's it's really cool.
It's very hard to do for a lot of people.
- Well, part of the reason
for that is we lost one
of our biggest sources
of new patients which is doctor referrals.
They're all in the corporate healthcare.
So we're going up against big Goliaths.
And we're just trying to figure out
how to add that third best referral source
into the business.
So number one is patient referrals,
number two would be
Google ad words and SEO
and then number three used to be doctor.
So I'm just looking for
that third strategy.
And I know digital has to be it,
that's where people are,
that's where the attention is,
but I don't really have a good strategy.
I'd done some, content.
I've done a lot of written
content, just in our field.
I've done some video content,
but I just feel like
we're not doing enough.
And I wanna reach.
- [Gary] Chris it's funny to jump in here.
I'm sorry you want to reach.
- One last thing is the 40 to
70 year old females, our demo.
That's really who we're looking for.
- Rather, what's really cool
about this is I'm actually
using Lauren as a comp.
People like, "I have this problem."
Like no, no, your problem
is you haven't dealt
with your childhood, right?
Or like Gary I didn't, no, no,
I have a major problem with my sink.
No, you don't, you're well
outside your water source
is your problem.
The reason I use those two things,
and I want everybody to hear this,
Chris, if you knew that
90% of your business
was how to do pictures
and videos on Facebook,
you would act differently every day.
What I need you to do
in these five minutes.
And I appreciate the
way you just responded.
Like, I don't, I'm not kidding you, you.
And then whether you hire people,
whether you freelance it,
whether you work with an agency,
you have to realize, that that's exactly
why you have to do it to your point.
And I appreciate your humility.
You didn't have the strategic
rationale or the burnout
or some other different
point of stepping back.
You were forced to because you relied
on something else driving your business.
I am never scared because
I never had let anyone
have leverage.
James will tell you that,
he knows the inside of me.
Literally everybody can leave the company
and there'll be (beep) disastrous
for an hour or a month or a year.
But I have so much leverage
and understanding that I'm
actually not vulnerable.
You were vulnerable.
Some of you else here are vulnerable.
You can't rely on somebody
driving your relationship
with your customer.
So this will now make sense,
which is why I'm using this.
It's not the Raz it's to get you fired up
to the next chapter.
You have to win Instagram and Facebook.
You, you, it's more
important than your practice,
your ability now, it's more important
than bouncing your cheque book.
It's more important than breathing oxygen.
You have to know what it is.
And it's Jason's answer too,
Jason will get destroyed in new markets.
If he doesn't understand it, he will.
It's just too much capital
upfront to wait for it to happen.
Unless he raises a ungodly amount of money
or he bleeds all his
base business dollars.
If he doesn't get good
at it, at least adequate,
it's not gonna work.
If you can't create growth.
One of the things I've
really enjoyed working
with James Orsini, he's he comes
from big holding company agency land,
where they are at such scale.
They are about efficiencies.
And it's been great for me to learn
because I've always created such growth,
but like that's why I'm never public.
When you're growing, when you
know how to get more business,
ironically all the other
(beep) works itself out.
It's when you stop knowing
how to get business,
that you have to become
a monster at efficiencies
but that's not a fun game.
It's depressing, firing
people, read negotiating.
Like it's all defense, (beep) defense.
So brother, you have to learn offense,
and the offense in your business
is how to acquire customers.
And the only way to acquire
customers for all of us,
including me in small business
land, is social media.
Nobody hears buying a
Superbowl commercial.
- That's great. I was putting
a little bit of attention
into taking your advice,
hosting the party, doing a podcast
called "Inspiring Small Business Stories".
- I love that, the problem
is you need people to listen.
And if you don't know how
to market the podcast,
you're gonna be looking
at yourself and saying,
"This is cool for my grandchildren
to listen to one day,
"cause it's funny."
But it's not driving your business,
by the way, what you're, now you're going,
think about how this works.
I love that, and I'm glad
you picked up on that.
And by the way, you should
do that, it's gonna work.
The problem is if you don't
know how to get people
to (beep) listen to it, it's all dead.
Knowing how to do
pictures, videos, cartoons
written words, and how to spend
a hundred dollars a media,
on LinkedIn, Snapchat,
Facebook, Twitter, TikTok,
is everyone's business here,
everything's secondary.
I don't give (beep) a how
good the stereo equipment
Esther's family has been
making for 50 (beep) years.
If she doesn't know how
to get people to come
to the (beep) store, it's game over,
or get or buy it on .com.
All of that I don't...
Delicious ice cream is subjective.
What's not subjective is that people
saw Zach and Courtney (beep)
in their feed and was like,
"(beep)I'll try it."
It's the only thing that matters.
It's why I'm completely been
obsessed about it for a decade,
not honing any other skill than trying
to become the single best practitioner
at the day trading of media and creative
on an every second basis.
And I would argue, that's why
I have just started my career
because I'm now in the
place where I'm recognized
as if, and it will only
compound from here.
'Cause everyone's about to get
educated the next 10 years.
That's the only thing that matters.
Comma, of course your product matters.
If the tire suck, of course,
but everyone here's thing is good enough,
to build a big enough business
to make everybody here happy
for the rest of their life.
They got to get this (beep) part right.
- I think we should move on
a little bit, I've got...
- And Chris, the reason I
went that route with you
is now anything you've heard prior
or anything that's coming up.
I just feel like you're
going to take it an 11
seriousness instead of an eight.
Got it, that's what I'm
trying to do here, right?
Like you gotta like get down to zero
and go, oh my God, this
is actually the business
I'm in, that I happen.
Everybody here, is a
marketing media company
that happens to do the
other things they say.
You happen to sell ice cream, tires.
You happen to.
- [Chris] Great.
- You happen to decide
to grow a weird mustache.
You've happen to
- Gary, we've got Geo and Antonio
that are getting ready
to launch an innovation.
So I figured innovation might
be a good change of pace.
Geo, go ahead.
- How are you doing?
Can you hear us?
- [Joe] Yes Geo.
- Yeah great.
So we're launching a new product.
Going live, doing live streaming right now
to a multiple destination is hard, right?
You have to be platform,
you have to be a re-stream
or a switchboard to do it.
So we have developed an app
where users can download it
and they can go, you can
add multiple social media.
So what you see here is
two Instagram, one Facebook
where you can do like five Facebook,
7 Instagram and then you do a live.
And when you do a live,
obviously you're going live
on all the different
social media channels.
And then you can actually see comments
coming in from Facebook, Instagram.
We are, we also adding...
- So similar Geo to Stream Yard, right?
- Yes, but mobile, by app based.
- I understand.
- So we're the first ones
in the world doing that.
And we're adding LinkedIn.
So we just got the approval from LinkedIn,
so it's pretty cool.
And we also had a spokesman,
an influencer Sinbad,
that was gonna be the spokesman.
You know him?
You got to know him.
- A comedian?
- [Geo] Yeah.
- I'm 45 years old.
- No, no, no, that's I
thought its gonna resonate.
But I don't know if you knew
that he just got a stroke like last week.
- Am so sorry.
- [Geo] I know, it sucks.
but he's doing better.
Anyway, so we wanted to know
if this was your product, right?
This is your app, well,
how would you market it?
- Geo, Anthony, is it ready
for me to try and use?
- [Joe] It's in the chat window,
If you wanna take a look at it.
- We put it in there.
- We'll do a separate thing,
Joe, why don't you set
them up with Andy and Sid.
- Will do.
- [Gary] We'll take this offline,
because I will absolutely play with it.
And then I can give you
a really, really, really
really good answer.
- [Geo] Beautiful.
- Awesome. Why don't we
slide over to Hawaii then,
and you already know Zach and Courtney,
but let me go ahead and chime in.
- Geo and Anthony,
we'll do that in the
first week of December.
We'll have a real meeting.
- [Geo] Beautiful
- Zack, Courtney, great
to see you guys again.
- [Courtney] Hi Gary, you too.
So, I mean, we're super interested
in what ideas do you have
for us from the last call,
especially around like
how to provide value
as a sustainable business model for us,
this because we're so early on.
I guess a specific question for us
is in terms of branding,
we have so many elements going on.
We have the story of Daniel,
like Daniel's real life.
We have the story of the Sage
which is gonna be like
a fictional character
that we want to use to inspire customers.
And then we also have
like Zach and Courtney
as the couple high school sweethearts,
starting a business together
during Corona virus.
So, and then the product itself, right?
The only organic made ice
cream using local products.
- You mean similar to empathy, right?
Where you had me and my origin
story, the product itself
the story of two interns
that became my partners,
the story of the farmers direct to bottle.
You mean like every brand in
the world, multiple stories.
This is one big session of and not or.
- Okay, so I mean we just,
- [Gary] All of it.
- All of it.
Yeah.
- [Courtney] Okay.
- And by the way, in the same screen,
this post is a beautiful
picture of ice cream.
The next one's the first
time you guys kissed
the next one is right.
The next is the siege.
The next is a new flavor.
The next is it.
And watch and listen, I
know a lot of you follow me.
That whole thing I talked about PCS
Post Traders Strategists.
The people that read all the copy that,
like that's a very big part of it.
You'll see after six
months of doing all of it,
which one has a little
more juice than others,
then you start all four
at 25% energy each,
but then four months later,
it's 60, 10, five, 22.
Got it.
You understand?
And by the way, it also ebbs and flows.
I don't know if any of you noticed this,
but the last two weeks,
my Instagram has taken a different tone.
I'm doing a lot more business content,
less mindset, less motivation,
more what I did in 2011 on the next wave,
more like here's why
Spotify is doing this,
power trying to be up.
Like now my views are down,
but I want to for my brand and for my soul
do more business content
'cause I'm a businessman.
And I feel like I've established
the mindset perspective
thing the last three years,
we've got that down again.
Now I'm gonna move away from it,
and I'm gonna be more in it.
You understand?
So not start at 25% each
for those four stories,
and really 20%, cause leave
the last 20% for anything.
Then you're gonna keep
going and going and going
and you're gonna ebb and flow
and it's gonna change for a year,
maybe it's all about your relationship
but then everyone's tired.
They know all your (beep) stories.
They know about the note in class,
and the first kiss and they
know what all that (beep).
But first of all, as you know,
everybody knows my lemonade
stand and all that,
I still pound it, but you're
going to ebb and flow it.
Got it.
- [Courtney] Yep, got it.
- Okay, I mean, we're trying to...
- [Gary] By the way, real quick,
just to make this more
valuable for everybody.
One part of your relationship
may work better on YouTube.
The sage might work better on TikTOK.
The flavors might be better on Instagram.
So there's also, not only
are the four strategies
and different flow, but
your distribution channels
might have different
percentages given the psychology
and the demographics within
that (beep) platform.
- [Courtney] Yeah.
So it won't be muddled if we are talking
about all of that.
- There's no muddled, that's a theory.
- [Courtney] Yeah, okay.
- And by the way, you're gonna watch.
And if you see like people really react
to the beautiful pictures of Instagram,
high res photos of ice cream,
then you're like (beep),
it we'll do 80% that.
But like people fear
staying in the same topic,
that makes people boring.
- [Courtney] Yeah, yeah, totally.
I guess like what ideas
did you have for us?
I mean, it sounded like
you had some cool ideas.
- I think sampling is the number one thing
that brands don't do enough of.
So anything that can create content,
so I'll give you an example,
if you did a thing on Instagram
that if you leave a comment
in the first minute,
we're going to pick one
person every time to
send free ice cream to, now it's a game.
Now you see things like,
but using sampling as
your leverage, right?
Make content for us in all your States,
and for the best one for each 50 States,
we'll send 50 people,
five cartons of ice cream.
Now you got content.
- [Courtney] Yeah.
Show us your freezer.
Like just creativity.
You see where I'm going, using sampling
because your product is delicious.
And so giving it away is good for you,
because once they taste
it, they can come back.
- [Courtney] Yeah.
Which is different than let's say
if you're selling power tools in Barbados
where they don't need it again.
That's not good, sampling's
not good for Toby.
If wine sampling was legal, cause alcohol,
you can't give away
for free in New Jersey.
I would constantly do it.
- So influencer marketing
would be good for us too then.
- [Gary] Influencer marketing
would be 100 very much.
(Courtney laughing)
- [Courtney] Okay.
- So now let's up to Esther,
Esther and Ryan are the last two
and they both have similar conundrums.
They're both in the sound space
but if in very different
reasons, Esther, talk to Gary.
You are on mute.
- Hi Gary.
So I'm like try to, can Ryan go?
'Cause I have so many things
that I wanna ask and I'm trying to see
what would be the best use of...
- [Joe] We're trying to get Ryan,
we're trying to get Gary
out of here in 10 minutes
but Ryan start us off and Esther,
hope if we have enough
time we'll come back.
- [Ryan] All right.
Well then, I'll try to
go as quick as possible.
Gary, you used the analogy
earlier about fixing the sink
versus fixing the well before
I could use your analogy.
I'm tryna fix my well, I'm tryna get out
of a career that I've been
stuck in for the last 14 years.
And I'm not fancy, my wife and I,
we have three kids,
we're lower middle-class.
I don't need to make a ton of money.
- [Gary] So great.
I just need to make enough,
- [Gary] Yeah I got it.
- to replace the career.
- Patience and execution every night.
Feverishness, this is, you know what?
One of my great mistakes of my career
was Ryan, is when I wrote crush it,
I talk about happiness over everything
the opportunity and internet.
And then I talked about Ryan Smith
and I talked about 7:00
p.m. to two in the morning.
I said, "If you are all out of options,
"if you can't get less fancy,
"if you can't, if you've
got no other options,
"you still have 7:00 PM
to two in the morning
" with the internet that our
grandparents didn't have."
If you were your grandfather,
you're stuck, the end,
this unstuck us.
Unfortunately for me, people manipulated
what I was saying, to me saying
that everybody has to work
at two o'clock in the morning and burnout,
which sucks, because I
don't want to be associated
with hustle porn, but here we are.
And the answer to you
is what I wrote in 2008.
And the book came out no nine,
which is, you have to be very strategic
about seven to 2:00 p.m.
You have to be patient,
because you still want
time with the family.
You got to take care of your health.
You got to be right, but
over a five-year window,
'cause you're a young man.
If you execute properly, in that time
you have a model to get
out of this situation.
Otherwise, without it, you
don't, and you go into depression
of never getting out of it
or you just live, way (beep).
You think you can't leave
more homily, you can,
do you own a house?
- We do, it's not very fancy, but yeah.
- You could sell it and rent
(beep) a place, you could.
I'm not saying you should.
I'm not saying it's fun too.
You could.
But the only thing I know
is taking one step back,
even more extremely than
you think, you could,
or what I get excited about
7:00 PM to two in the morning,
in a balanced way, amortized
over a long period of time.
So it's healthy around the
thing that's gonna take you
to the next place.
- One of the things I don't
know if you saw the email
or not, but one of the
things my wife and I made
'cause we were supposed
to go to a senior bowl
to see was a poster that
said Vaynerchuk debts.
And on the other side of it
it said we'll sell our house
and move to Chattanooga to work for you.
So my wife's on board, like
we're willing to downsize.
- And what do you wanna do?
- I want to design and deliver
amazing entertainment experiences
to people through home
theater and audio and video.
Like that's my passion,
that's what I've been doing
for like 23 years.
- When you say design, you mean being
like the interior decorator strategist
of what somebody should
do for their home theater?
- Not necessarily the
interior decorating part,
but more of the system engineering.
- Got it, the technical architecture
of what if Nick Deo makes a big one day
and he's like I need this Epic theater,
and you're like, what's your budget?
And he says, "80 K."
You're gonna make the best use of that
for the most Epic up
to date infrastructure.
- 100%.
- So that bleeds into
your world a little, huh?
- Yes, for sure.
- So that's what you wanna do, right?
Can I make a huge recommendation to you?
- Of course.
- [Gary] That I'm really bullish on that.
I'm like praying to God works
because it'll be an amazing case study
and you'll be happy (beep)
as with me and forever.
I think you should share
in long written posts
and video potentially on
LinkedIn, make pretend scenarios.
Hey guys, "Its Ryan."
I mean whether this is an article,
I'll do my version of the videos from,
"Hey guys, it's Ryan Smith here again
"with the make pretend set up show,
"where I take a theoretical budget
"and a theoretical scenario,
"and I customize that person's
"home entertainment experience.
"Here we go, on today's episode,
"make pretend lawyer Rick on
the upper East side has $67,000
"for his new Hamptons home.
"He's got two kids that are seven.
"So he wants that Disney
plus (beep) to be on fire.
"Let's get into the show.
"All right, so I got $67,000.
"I got plenty of room.
"It's not about the couches."
That, if you go that on LinkedIn
in written or audio or video form,
once a week,
it is my belief in my, that
something weird will happen.
And for everybody's not
following something weird
is a company is gonna reach out to you
and say, "We wanna hire you to do this ad,
"but you have to keep doing this show,
"because we need more
contemporary marketing.
"And we think your face matters"
or Bose sees it,
or Esther sees it,
or somebody sees it in the business
and it goes the other route
and makes you an influencer
for their business.
I want you to, as a doctor
writing a prescription,
I want you to do what I just
said once a week on LinkedIn.
And after you do 10 of them,
I want you to share the 10th one with me
via email titled here's my 10th one,
cc Joe Q to make sure I don't miss it.
And I will give it a little bit
of awareness if I like what
you've done in your first 10.
- We'll do it.
Absolutely, thank you.
- [ Gary] You're welcome.
- Anyway Gary and Ryan, we're
already connected on LinkedIn.
So I'll make sure you're
up on your 10 posts
and Gary It'll be coming hot
in your inbox when it does.
Esther, do you have your question ready?
- Yes I do.
Okay, fine.
So Binyomin wanted to say hi to you.
- Its great to see you again Binyomin.
And what did you wanna tell Gary?
What do you wanna be when you grow up?
- An entrepreneur and a business man.
- My man, you will be.
- And that he made this for you.
He wanted to show.
- [Gary] Ah, you're very sweet.
- Yeah, okay.
So really quickly.
- Very nice.
- So this is one of,
this is where I like lost
my train of thought,
and I feel like this is
like the most important
question that I have,
because I have a lot of the
solutions of what I need to do,
but here's my issue.
We have this brand, right?
That is a world-class brand.
You tell, you ask pretty
much any audio file,
that's serious about audio.
And then they'll say lamb industries,
is like the Bentley of
audio, whatever, fine.
We operated as like a mom and pop shop,
kind of like the same mentality
that your dad had yet.
You were able to scale it and
take it to the next level.
- Yes
- [Esther] I was not able to do that,
within that scope of time,
whatever it is, it's fine.
Everything happens at its right time.
I feel like now's my time to launch,
I know that all the things
that I need to do really,
yes, of course I could do content myself
and hire somebody, even get interns,
and like that's what I was actually doing,
setting up people who were like interests
in high-end audio, for the
experience to be with us.
They're gonna do free
content for us, amazing.
But I really need an investor.
Like, there's just no way around it,
but not just an investor.
I had a fundraising career prior to this.
If I needed just money, I could get money.
I need somebody that's
gonna be super passionate,
and is gonna be interested
in my father's like.
- [Gary] Esther, the sort
of the problem with that is,
and I've heard this a lot lately
in my VC hat on and that life,
everybody wants smart strategic money,
that only really comes in a partner.
- Right, we're willing to do that.
- [Gary] I believe you
- And what am saying...
- I want you to be thinking that way.
- [Esther] I am for sure, 100%
- Good
- Because I feel like we have,
I always say that like,
"We're on a gold, we're
sitting on a gold mine."
Like we have brand equity that
companies would be spending,
I'm not exert, probably
millions of dollars
to get to where we are,
just with my father
like name recognition and where we're at.
And under it, I want to launch,
and I spoke to people before,
I know how to do what,
even though I don't have per se the,
I have the head for it, I
don't know the expertise
in terms of running an
operations, manufacturing,
I grew up with my dad,
I know certain things,
like I would launch little
lamp and all the dealers,
every dealer distributor that I spoke to
they loved the idea.
They wanna integrate an amp,
which means two of those
bulky things in one, right?
Especially for people who are like,
I'm not putting this
whole freaking system,
in my two bedroom, whatever
Manhattan apartment,
but I want a good stereo,
and I'm willing to spend 50,000, 40,000.
Then you have the younger guys who are,
like I'm sure the guys who work for you,
who could spend 20, 30 even 10,000,
I will go as low as like
$10,000 entry points
and then build them up to
the lamb industries brand.
I have it all planned out.
I have a business plan,
I have it all written up.
My issue is like, so do I approach people
that I know from the fundraising world
and try to find a partner that way?
Do I shop it around, you
know what I'm saying?
Or do I put it all in God and say,
"God's gonna send me the..."
- Oh, God's undefeated.
So you can do that.
But if you wanna...
- You know what am saying?
- [Gary] Of course I do.
But if you wanna hedge it a little bit,
I think it's similar to
the advice I gave Ryan,
which is, I think you put
it out to the universe.
I think sharing that you're looking
for a partner in crime and
here's what you're looking for.
And I really, everyone hear me out.
TikTOK has crazy organic reach,
you've all heard of this
from nauseum for me.
LinkedIn has crazy organic reach.
If you go tell the world that
this is happening once a week,
for nine weeks in a row on LinkedIn.
I can't tell you Esther,
how much I believe
that it's gonna lead
to you finding someone.
- And like do I really
want to like put out,
I here what you're saying.
- Yes, you do.
I'll tell you why?
Because you can disguise it.
I understand what you're saying.
Like you don't go ahead,
I think you disguise it.
Hey, is there any,
I think you make it look like an employee
or like a partnership or like a service,
but really underneath,
that's what you're looking for.
And you're hoping back to God's hands,
that that person actually is like,
"Wait a minute"
I mean, here's a good one.
James Orsini will tell
you, the Sasha Group
or even Vayner Consulting before,
at the precursor to Sasha Group
and Nick Deo and Joe know that Dennis Dog,
we had great employee, he was doing
what joke you and Nick and James are doing
a came a business in one of these sessions
that he really liked.
And he left our company to
become partners with that person.
So I think you can put it out
there, not as a desperation
or as a, I need a partner,
but as a partnership.
- Right.
- [Gary] And then you could vet it
through the people that come in.
- Right.
Because like, when you speak
about marketing dollars
like just a one idea because of COVID,
we don't go to movie theaters, right?
Drive throughs.
Like my dad, I always ask them,
can I dad, can we use your
amps for like music festivals?
Can we use your amps for things
like movie theater things,
which traditionally before,
and my dad saw dealer, has
these crazy Japanese speakers
that were used, he answered my question.
We're doing this documentary
and my dad called the purist,
and one of our customers is the C...
I mentioned this to the group earlier,
is all the CEO of Atlantic Records,
who's was the nicest guy, big audio file.
And he has like 1.5 million LPS,
he has like the largest collection of LPS.
So there was a lot of...
- [Gary] Creig?
- [Esther] Yeah.
- Creig Kallman
- [Esther] Creig Kallman
- Yeah, I know Creig really well.
A couple of banks, Esther.
'Cause I know we'll be
able to connect again.
I have to run cause I
can't be late for the vote,
because we have a vote at
one, three minutes ago.
I love everybody.
Thank you everyone.
- Great Gary
- Thank you.
- YouTube watcher, what's up?
It's Gary Vee, first of
all, thank you so much.
I hope you're doing super
well during these times.
I also wanna ask you please subscribe,
because my commitment and exploration
of YouTube is about to
explode stories, polls
more content, more engagement,
more surprise, and delight.
This is the time to subscribe.
I hope you consider it.
And I hope I see you soon.